alors on va poser des questions sur les
3t sur vous et si vous perdez bien sûr
vous serez coller un pendant la pub
première question quel est le titre du
duo des 3t avec leur tonton michael je
mangeais dépistage à venir sa mère des
fans du cd pisano qui n'est en plus pas
sait plus quoi c'est beaucoup et on est
rentré alors franchement tu bosses pas
les émissions sébastien alors francs par
an je suis fan de michael jackson mais
des 3t mais je ne sais pas là alors
c'est quoi la réponse est oui c'est moi
qui dit qui veut dire arts et bien sûr
pourquoi n'at on aborda la vidéo temps
n'a pas influé mois
[Musique]
pourquoi
ils ne
j'étais nu comme on voyait ses images
avec michael jackson avec votre oncle ou
pas vraiment aimé y as hier c'était la
quatrième et une clip que nous fassions
et donc on n'avait pas rencontré
beaucoup de succès s'attendait soit
extrêmement professionnelle extrêmement
sérieux comme vous pouvez le voir sur
scène on souhaite juste passer du bon
temps et ont plaisanté en permanence
donc c'est en raison de la relation
qu'on entretenait avec un coeur parce
que en fait en coulisse avec nous et
bien c'est quelqu'un c'était quelqu'un
de très heureux et rigolait beaucoup et
il blaguait beaucoup michael jackson
wavre est vraiment choquant encore
sourire aujourd'hui il avait un reer
extrêmement affectueux extrêmement
joyeux je l'entends encore aux chances
vous il vous manque
il vous manque ou pas énormément
c'est vrai quoi battre cet endroit que
le jury n'a pas ils vont pas te dire non
non que je n'ai pas moi j'ai disons
qu'on attendait pas de métier qu'est ce
qui vous manque beaucoup c'est vrai ben
oui mais attendez donc un coeur mais n'a
qu'un rêve et naïm et en a arrêté
bon c'est pas parce que votre eau comme
babouche ils n'ont pas voilà non mais
parce que la non tout le maroc
barbouch on embrasse d'ailleurs salama
les confréries sartec les magasins hart
est le souk deuxième question cette fois
son make up d'accra ils vont pouvoir et
plus incollables haïdar collab sur
maicon est celle-là il a deux sujets où
il est adorable
michael jackson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ils veulent tous michael jackson on
dirait que l'ami des électrodes ces gens
l'électrostimulation feu doux alors tout
à l'heure si vous perdez ce sera pendant
voilà comment un pub mais vous serez
déguisant michael jackson un oeuf corse
bas au plus je sens que vous avez vous
partez bien fait par rapport aux cheveux
non pas roux souffre et moi non ah ouais
ouais
oui il ya ça va engager sa part le mini
bar où logent les débats sur la tête de
ma mère ge
il a soufflé mon frère sur ma vie c'est
même moi je suis contrôlé c'est ce qu'on
lui montre
la mère voulait sentir une vente
imminente et l'alcool
[Applaudissements]
les débats miliband on est d'accord
contient des routes et zz laisse
rappelle que l'alcool est dangereux pour
la santé de la rance pire au bout de
trois secondes de dents à la restaurer
on dirait qu à l huile sans rien dire
est qu'il ait fait un concert de deux
heures et demie d'énoncé pour débourrer
mon vieux il a fêté la fin d'année
mamelles qu'ils en font sa peau c'est le
seul mec qui fait la fin d'année trois
semaines avant pâques tient la maison
tire aller chercher toi-même ce jour
voilà des paquets la maison est tout le
temps se fait courser pour elle allez
bon été que s'est il passé pour michael
jackson le 16 mai 1983 il a sorti son
premier album solo
il a réalisé son premier moonwalk
isabelle morini bosc a fêté ses 70 ans
oui beaucoup vient il a gagné à roland
garros je sais non mais on s'en fout
séduire les non non c'est le premier
moonwalk ou pas ça mais non nom est
personne non non gilles a dit que vous
savez faire
non c'est tellement drôle parce qu'on
croit très bien lorsqu on était jeunes
on en a eu beaucoup
notre oncle bien entendu nous avons
confiance et beaucoup de personnes ont
regardé et donc la pression était trop
forte
donc on a arrêté dans ses autres pairs
tito c'était le guitariste jackson five
qu'on s'est concentré sur sur la guitare
voix la guitare et moi sur la danse
c'est comme francis cabrel
bonjour anne on est très à l'est alors
je suis pas du tout je suis gracieux
[Applaudissements]
c'est un symbole c'est quoi ça c'est
juste un mec bourré qui marche en
arrière et touahri des bayonnais la
vérité c'est que vous êtes bourrés
retrouver votre beau retrouver
maintenant chercher moi tout ça me rend
agressif l'alcool on attend pas parler
pour voir ben moi j'ai mon luxe a pu
mais moi au sabot basse à son chameau tu
auras tu vas sortir la boss tu vas te
calmer regardez c'était en 83 regarder
[Musique]
pour moi
ein volk
[Applaudissements]
c'est fou comme ça ah ouais comment il a
eu l'idée de le voir cette suite ont
traduit chez lui tranquille vous dit
michael avait moins de bouteilles d'eau
la ferronnerie les titres phares comme à
cenon mais c'est vrai c'est ouf et les
deux la nuit de est tombé d'un bear
l'année dollars libreville 4 l équipe
qui recule et bouira complément
d'information oui et c'est sur smooth
commune que pour la première fois il
fait tu sais le truc comme ça dans ses
mocassins à 45 degrés et le moins que je
croie qu'il s'était inspiré du mime
marceau et de sophie marceau aussi
qu'ici n'importe quoi quatrième question
je passe à la quatrième
à oui à la minute près ababou burida
durée du clip thriller de michael
jackson alors quelle version 11 minutes
et la longue balle allons à la longue
version 1
on doit être sur ce que vous savez vous
d'abord je voudrais vous aider des
personnes à peu près comme un éclat la
connaissez pas les devants de michael
jackson
[Applaudissements]
alors toi je pense que c'est chaud dans
mes tournées autour de l'île étroite et
15 minutes 47 secondes 15 minutes 47
secondes minutes est bien la bonne
réponse je vous la donne et juste après
le bref extrait ou pizza après la minute
[Musique]
j'adore franchement c'est mythique
jenny mythique sécurité à l'époque ça
peut en fait d'une certaine manière nous
emmener dans ses tournées on devait tous
avoir l'air être fou et un moment donné
on arrivait il ce parquet qui se
garaient quelque part elle se tourner
vers nous on était assis à l'arrière de
la voiture et nous disait moi je ne suis
pas comme les autres comme il est fait
d'un clip c'est effrayant mais un jour
on était suffisamment âgés pour
comprendre qu'il n'allait pas se
transformer en loup c'est drôle on a
franchement j'adore
ils sont formidables étroite et vraiment
je contente pour encadrer ces échéances
[Applaudissements]
je suis fan
attention vous avez quand même poids
castaldi j'ai quinze minutes 47 secondes
ouais mais si tu étais un homme âgé ou
les 10 et 13 minutes 42 c était pas loin
c'est l'histoire de deux volets avec les
meufs et 9 cm
il est toujours à sa tête toujours à ça
de ma mère quel chanteur a co écrit
michael jackson venue le titre who are
the world
ils peuvent non sûrement pas alors
allez-y c'est qu'il est noir alors à
deux secondes
si vous perdez vous chantez vous allez
danser on va essayer c'est line and
which he
bâle est aussi ses valises et faudel oui
c'est des red river est un titre sorti
un pour l'association usa for africa qui
récoltait des fonds pour qu'on pour
contrer la famine en afrique vous étiez
dans le clip on voit métier non vous
n'étiez pas les mecs une autre version
il ya de quoi va-t-on après peut-être
way et oui c'est vraiment prises tant
que new dawn 1ère et adore oui oui nous
le faire là avoue une vente est reconnu
c'était un hymne à regarder
[Applaudissements]
m
allez
en corée
taha
[Musique]
attention à la bulle
dernière question benjamin castaldi
commence à presles comment s'appelle
l'album des 3t l'aide sans lui les
bourgs il allait mourir elles vont
mourir plus de mémoire war 2 1 ch
acteurs français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les 3t chaque pays entre faire à la
cigale le 1er septembre mme étroite et
juraient vous remercier d'avoir été avec
mais franchement c'est un honneur de
vous avoir bassamois casta diva est sûr
c'est qu'il est dans un instant
bourret et en ma gueule c'est bien sûr
un moment à ne pas manquer